foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar building
panels for flow cytometry key steps to
success
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elabroots and brought to
you by scitec biosciences to learn more
please visit scitecbio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation I'd like to
now welcome our speaker Dr Laura
Johnston technical application
specialist at scitec biosciences
Laura welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
okay so I am going to cover a lot of
pamel design best practices today and I
want to start out by saying or making
the point that pretty much everything I
talk about today you can apply to all
platforms and panels of all sizes so it
doesn't matter if you're using a
conventional cytometer or a full
spectrum cytometer or whatever panel
size you are using I should be able to
give you some really good information
today now of course depending on
scenario that you're in you might want
to use slightly different strategies so
as I go through the uh talk today and I
talk about these panel design best
practices I'm going to do so using three
different scenarios as examples so the
first scenario is your smaller simple
panels and really this is the basic
information that everyone should find
useful this is the second scenario is
for those of you who may be interested
in doing something that's a little bit
larger a little bit more complex I'm
going to give you some strategies to
um
apply to that specific scenario
and then the third situation is for
those of you who may be running a panel
on cells that have high autofluorescence
I'll talk about exactly what that is how
you figure out if you're in that
situation and some tips for that
specific scenario so remember these
three scenarios I'm going to go through
them as I go through the talk and I'll
call these back
okay so for the workflow and the main
structure of this talk I'm going to be
talking about uh the panel design
process and four steps and it really
should be informed so to start out we
are going to gather information so the
first thing we want to gather
information about is the biology we want
to know our scientific question
um and what populations we are
interested in investigating
the second step is we're going to gather
information about the fluorochromes and
that's going to come down to our
cytometer configuration and and we'll
also talk about some characteristics of
the fluorochrome so that you can combine
them together in a panel
the third stump is where it gets
interesting we're going to start pairing
the markers to the fluorochromes to
design our actual panel now this is not
the last step there is a step after that
which we're calling the optimization and
this is where you're actually going to
be able to determine if your panel is
successful or not
so we're going to walk through all four
of these steps using the examples that I
outlined on the previous slide and let's
start with our first step which is the
biology we're going to talk about how
you go about selecting markers the level
of expression and thinking about
co-expression
so starting out we really want to have
it clear in our mind what is our
scientific question what are we trying
to address that will help us understand
what populations we're are interested in
looking at with our panel design
now if you are looking at in immune
markers you could think about these
different loose groups of markers this
is just an example strategy you don't
necessarily have to use this but it can
be helpful so our first group is lineage
markers let's say you're interested in T
cells so the lineage marker for T cells
is CD3 we would want to include that in
our panel
the second marker or the second group is
additional markers so maybe we're
interested in subsetting T cells further
so if we want to include CD4 and cd8 to
subset our T cells those would Loosely
go into the additional markers group
if you're interested in exclusion
markers you may not include these but if
you would like to exclude certain
subtypes from your panel let's say I
only want to look at T cells and I don't
want to look at B cells I may include a
B cell marker as an exclusion marker so
that I can remove those from my analysis
and then other markers it's just
dependent on your scientific questions
so maybe you're interested in cytokine
receptors or activating receptors
whatever you may have
now having these loose groups can uh be
useful when you're thinking about the
next step which is co-expression so for
lineage markers oftentimes one lineage
marker is mutually exclusive from
another lineage marker so our CD3 is not
going to be co-expressed on a totally
different cell type like a neutrophone
our additional markers our CD4 and cd8
oftentimes those are co-expressed with
our lineage markers so we know that CD4
and cd8 are going to be coax brassed
with CD3
and then our exclusion markers we have
specifically put those in so that they
are not they're going to remove cells
that we're not interested in so they're
not going to be coax breast with any
markers that are on our cells of
Interest
that's one way to start thinking about
coexpression there are a few other ways
so one these are some visual methods on
the left here we have a cell lineage
tree and we can see at the bottom of
that we have CD3 that's been used to
define our T cells but the CD3 is not on
our NK cells so that's another way to
think about things or on the right side
we have a gating strategy now you can do
a rough gating strategy like this where
you just sort of loosely plan out how
you're going to get your populations of
Interest or you may actually go into
Publications and find some real data
that will actually show you populations
in these plots but we can see for
example cd56 and cd16 on the second plot
we're looking at a few different
populations even a double positive
population with these markers
uh with the list of markers we also want
to start thinking about region
availability you're probably going to be
purchasing antibodies from various
vendors and so we want to know what is
available so we can put those into our
panel
we also want to be thinking about clones
not all clones behave similarly so it's
important to learn about what clones are
available and what people are using in
Publications and then experimental
conditions if you're doing anything to
yourselves maybe if you're stimulating
them thinking about how your markers are
going to be affected by those
experimental conditions
so there's a lot of research or there's
a lot of information out there I would
encourage you to do some research as an
example in the green box we have what
you can find on the region page for
scitec bio.com you'll find information
about clones
fluorophores oftentimes vendors will
give you information about the markers
as well so that's one starting place
that you can go to to look for
information about reagents you can also
look at Publications so if you're
interested in NK cells for example maybe
you are maybe you find this publication
and you can learn about the markers how
they're defining the NK populations you
can pull information about clones from
papers so it's really good to do some
research on the field that you're
looking at
another option I want to highlight is in
the journal cytometry part A there are a
subset of papers called omips that
stands for optimize multi-color
immunofluorescence panels and these are
really focused on panels people have
spent a lot of time optimizing these
panels and they will give you all the
information in these papers so there's
really a ton of good information and
this is really a great starting point
for you to look through these various
omics
and then a last reference that I will
point out is this paper in Frontiers in
Immunology if you're interested in human
markers
specifically human immune markers there
is this paper that gives you a ton of
information about the CD markers
numbered one through a hundred so that
another great resource there but again
do your research and figure out what is
available in your field
when you have your list of markers you
also need to start categorizing your
markers that's going to be very critical
when we get to this step we're preparing
to our markers to our floor crumbs the
categories come from this paper that is
referenced in the lower right hand
corner by monkey and rotorer the
categories are primary secondary and
tertiary so a primary marker is very
high density typically has an on off
pattern so you can see in that data plot
there the cells either have the marker
or they don't and there's no in between
here
the secondary marker however you could
describe it as its intermediate density
or maybe it has a continuous expression
so we have both low density and high
density antigens and we want to be able
to resolve all of that expression
and then our tertiary markers are our
low density markers or potentially our
unknown expression now note about
unknown if you yourself do not know what
the expression is do some research see
if somebody out there knows what it is
but if really nobody knows maybe that's
the whole point that you're doing this
experiment then you can categorize it as
a tertiary marker and so it's important
to understand these categories because
when you get to pairing your markers
with fluorochromes you need to make sure
that the tertiary markers specifically
get paired with very bright
fluorochromes because if you pair a
tertiary marker with a dim fluorochrome
you will not be able to optimally
resolve it
so moving on to the fluorochromes let's
talk about information we need to learn
about the fluorochrome starting out with
the instrument as well as some criteria
for selecting the fluorochromes
for the instrument it's really critical
that you understand the specific
instrument that you're going to be using
for this panel particularly particularly
there are two points that we want to
understand the first has to do with the
lasers so what lasers are available to
excite the fluorochromes that you're
going to be selecting typically the
information we want to know there is the
wavelengths of each fluorochrome or
sorry each lizard and then the second
question has to do with how the
instrument is going to be detecting
these fluorochromes and so this is
probably the only point where I'm going
to mention a difference between a
conventional cytometer and a spectral
cytometer because those are configured a
little bit differently
so our example image on the right there
is a five laser Aurora which is a full
spectrum cytometer and the way that this
instrument is configured is we have a
detector array that matches each laser
so five lasers have five matching
detector arrays and ultimately there's
going to be a grand total of 64
detectors in this system and all of
these detectors are going to be utilized
to pick up the floor for admission for
all of the fluorochromes so actually if
you're using a spectral system it
becomes incredibly easy because all we
need to know is what lasers are on board
because we know there's a matching
detector module and that's really all
the information that is needed
uh it's also great to know that the
scitec instruments are very standardized
configuration and so all of the tools
I'm about to go through will be
applicable to all of the scitec
instruments for a conventional system
it's a teeny bit harder you're going to
know exact you're going to need to know
exactly what your system is configured
as so you need to know how many
detectors are present exactly what
wavelengths they can detect
so another way to look at this here is a
five laser scitec Aurora again the
detectors all 64 of them are on the
x-axis here and so you can see the
signal that we're getting from this
particular fluorophore it's going to be
picked up by all 64 detectors whereas if
we have a conventional system we're
going to be instead assigning a single
detector
specifically where the emission Maxima
is and so on a conventional system your
data would actually look like this
um so it's just a single detector
now let's go into the criteria for
selecting fluorochromes there are three
criteria that we're going to go through
the first one is uniqueness so we want
to make sure we're selecting
fluorochromes that can be distinguished
from each other
the second is brightness as I mentioned
we want to pair the brightness of the
floor chrome based on the antigen
density and the third one is spread
which is a slightly more advanced topic
that I will explain in detail and point
out those of you who need to pay more
close attention to the spread
so in terms of the uniqueness if you're
using a scitec system we try to make
this super easy for you and the way we
do that is we give you this value called
this similarity index so that's a value
that's between 0 and 1 and Compares two
fluorochromes let's go through some
examples
so we have buv395 in green and seafloor
r720 in purple if you look at that
second plot in the middle there you can
see there's no overlap between these two
fluorochromes so because there's no
overlap we have a similarity index of
zero it means the Spectra are completely
unique and in our data plot we can see
that we can Define these populations
really nicely with these fluoro crumbs
if we take the second example now we're
using APC and Alexa floor 647 in this
case we have a lot more overlap and our
similarity index is 0.9 so this value
tells us that we can use these in a
panel together on a scitec system
however I will note that these on a
conventional system will typically be
assigned to the exact same detector so I
would not recommend putting these
together in the same panel on a
conventional system but for a spectral
system we can do that and you can see
the data plot below looks very nice
then we have our third example which is
bv786 and super bright 780 these have a
solar similarity index of one and you
can see that our data plot below there
does not look very nice we can't resolve
our populations and so we should not be
using these four crumbs together in a
panel because we cannot distinguish them
so using the guidelines at the Top If
the similarity index is 0.99 or 1 then
don't put them in a panel together if
it's between 0.94 and 0.98 we would
recommend doing some testing it's going
to depend on the markers that you select
for those fluorochromes as to whether or
not you can resolve them but anything
below that you should be able to
distinguish and unfortunately for a
conventional system I don't have a
matching metric you're just going to
have to understand your specific
configuration and what fluorochromes you
can detect
now for the similarity index we
typically show you in a grid like this
so that triangular shaped grid there has
all the similarity index indices inside
of it but you may want to think about a
different metric so uh what about all of
the colors combined together this is the
similarity index only Compares two
fluorochromes so in this example we have
14 colors
and if we look overall we have a
complexity index a different metric that
will describe all 14 of them combined
and in this case it's 7.89 so the
complexity index gives us an overall
measure of uniqueness and unlike the
similarity index it doesn't have a hard
cutoff value the complexity index
instead just gives us a rough estimate
of if it's lower than it generally means
that is an easier combination of dies to
work with
so to give you a point of reference our
14 Color Kit is 7.89 if you have a
smaller panel your complexity index may
be something like 4.02 but if you go
much larger like our 40 color panel the
complexity index is 53.7 I don't want
you to get too hung up on the precise
values just that there's a relative
comparison of lower values are easier to
work with higher values are harder to
work with I'll give you some examples of
exactly why that is
so the second metric is brightness
um and in order to quantify brightness
we generally use this metric gain index
so the calculation is shown there it
basically just tells us how well we can
separate a positive population from a
negative population
and so ultimately what's most important
to understand from the stain index
calculation is that there are multiple
factors that impact it
um the actual scene index itself as well
as the signal intensity so the factors
are antigen expression fluorochrome
brightness instrument sensitivity or
setup and antibody performance so if you
change any of these factors it could
impact what your ultimate signal
intensity is so in order to come up with
a tool for panel design to figure out
what is the brightness of the
fluorochrome we need to basically fix
all these factors and just change the
floor curb brightness and ultimately
that's how we came up with this tool
where we ranked over 100 Floor crumbs on
a five laser system
and so if you use this chart it will
basically tell you that if you're
looking at a fluorochrome on the right
side of the chart then that is generally
a very bright fluorochrome and if you're
looking at one on the left side of the
chart there is that's a very dim
fluorochrome so use this as a general
estimate it is a continuous scale you
can see even though we've boxed it into
four categories it's continuous value
and these can be helpful as you're
designing your panel
okay let's get into some actual examples
I'm going to be going through those uh
scenarios that I talked about in the
beginning so I put a little icon in the
upper right hand corner to designate
which scenario I'm talking about so in
this case we're talking about scenario
one which is our small simple panels
so everyone's going to start out with a
small panel and then some of you might
be building it bigger so to start out I
would recommend that your simplest
approach for selecting a group of
fluorochromes is to pick fluorophores
that are both excited by different
lasers and have different emission
Maxima so in this example that I have
here I've selected five fluorochromes
for a five laser system they're all
excited by different lasers and we can
see the emission maximum listed at the
top there ranges from 395 nanometers to
774 nanometers
however if I was instead to select this
combination where now these five
fluorochromes are all excited by the
exact same laser this is certainly not
an impossible panel to use you could
find success with this panel however it
is probably going to be just a little
bit more challenging to design this
panel compared to the panel on the left
you just have to use a little bit more
caution
um or a little you have to be a little
more thoughtful that's a better word
um if you're using the combination on
the right so I would say it's easier to
start out on the left and then as you
build your panel larger and larger we
want to make sure that we're continuing
to keep everything spread out we want to
minimize our similarity and complexity
index indices
so moving to our next example as you
notice in the upper right hand corner
we've now switched to the second example
with a larger complex panel let's look
at a 15 color panel I'm going to call
this one panel a and in this case I've
put our Fluor crumbs into our panel
Matrix so let me describe the pound
Matrix so you can figure out how we can
use this panel Matrix to assess our
panel so the panel Matrix is set up with
the columns designating lasers and
that's going to position our
fluorochrome based on the primary
exciting laser so the First Column is UV
and so inside of that column we have
buv396 which is excited primarily by the
UV laser whereas on the right side we
have the red laser and in that column we
have seafloor r659 which is primarily
excited by the red laser
the um
the the rows are going to designate the
approximate emission
and so uh the top row is 395 nanometers
and the bottom row is 800 nanometers and
So based on that information we place
fluorophores in The Matrix and so we can
see just visually that everything is
pretty well spaced out spread relatively
evenly across all of the lasers there
and in our panel a we can see in the top
the complexity index is 4.1
so let's switch this to panel B which
still is 15 colors but now the
complexity index is 12.96 and we'll
notice that our fluorochromes are
centralized all in the center of this
panel Matrix as opposed to being spread
out
even if we focus on the blue laser we'll
see that we have two scenarios where we
have a cluster of three fluorochromes
stacked on top of each other as well as
if we look in the same row we have three
floor crumbs in the same row indicating
that they all have the same approximate
emission Maxima even though they are
excited by separate lasers so if you
have fluorochromes placed in the panel
Matrix like this this can indicate that
your panel is a little bit more
challenging to work with this is
certainly not an impossible panel to use
but you're going to be a little bit more
thoughtful when you design your panel so
why is panel B more difficult than panel
a it comes to our third topic which is
spillover spreading error which we often
just abbreviate to spread
so spread has to do with spectral
overlap and I'm going to walk you
through what that means and then we're
going to revisit panel a and panel B so
in this example we're going to use PEC 5
and APC as our example fluorochromes
this is run on a spectral instrument but
honestly you can even pretend this is a
conventional instrument so we have three
rectangles there you can imagine that
those are three separate detectors on a
conventional instrument so the blue
rectangle in the middle we would
typically on a conventional system
assign that to pesi5 because it captures
the emission Maxima of PE sci-fi whereas
the red rectangle would be assigned to
APC because it captures the emission
Maxima of APC but you'll notice what's
different between the red box and the
blue box is that in the red box we are
also seeing PE size 5 signal in addition
to APC signal so if I said this in a
sentence I would say that PE PSI 5 is
spilling into the detector assigned to
APC
now this is before we've calculated any
compensation or unmixing so if we
actually go ahead and calculate that
that's where we would start to visualize
this spillover spreading error and so if
we look at the APC positive population
we see that there's minimal spread our
positive population is nice round
compact population whereas the PEC 5
positive population is much more spread
out so this is the spreading error that
we're talking about uh and the result or
the reason for this is because the PEC 5
is spilling into the APC
now it is important to understand that
spread can be impacted by multiple
factors so I mentioned one of those
factors which is spectral overlap and
that's why selecting floors that have
that are unique have a low complexity
index that will help minimize the amount
of spectral overlap
but there's also additional factors so
the brightness of the impacting floor as
well as the antigen density so those two
things will impact the overall final
intensity of your positive population
and as you can see in that third example
as that intensity gets brighter and
brighter you can see that there is more
spread so some people call this the
trumpet effect or the umbrella effect
because this is a pretty classical
pattern of spread now one important
thing you will note that I did not say
anything about a conventional system or
a spectral system impacting spread so
that is not going to change your spread
especially if you have a panel that is
working well on a conventional system
and you decide to use that exact same
panel on a spectral system you
absolutely will not get more spread at
worst you would get the exact same
amount of spread as you did on the
conventional system or depending on the
panel and the the systems you're using
maybe you might even get a little bit
less spread on the spec system
now how do we assess this for panel
design we use a tool called the sir
Matrix this is something you could
calculate for your actual panel but what
we've done here is giving you a tool to
assess the worst case scenario so we ran
CD4 on all these floor crumbs listed
here and calculated the SAR Matrix to
assess the worst potential spread that
you could get or a pretty bad case of it
if you want to do this on your system
you would either have to figure out if
anyone has done this for your specific
configuration or you can make it
yourself but the way you would read this
Matrix is the die in the row impacts the
die in the column so let's choose a row
and see how our data gets impacted
so our first row is C4 b515 and we're
going to compare that how is that going
to impact the resolution of the
fluorochrome or the marker that we've
assigned to the fluorochrome in the
column
so if we look at our data here because
that box is white so there's no impact
and we can definitely see that in the
data we're not seeing any spread of
seafloor b515 into c4v420
but if we go along the row to a place
where there's a red box now we're seeing
that there is spread into seafloor b532
which is the right plot there so in
terms of panel design we need to think
about what is the antigen density and
how we're pairing our markers to these
fluorochromes that are on the y-axis of
these two plots here so if you have a
marker that is placed where that green
circle is then you should be able to
resolve your data and notice how for the
plot on the right we need a little bit
more space between the positive and
negative population to account for that
spread but if we were to use a low
density antigen on that C4 b532 then we
risk not being able to properly resolve
that population because of the spreading
error
so back to our panel a and panel B why
is panel B more challenging it's because
panel B has more spread and if we look
at the sir Matrix compared to panel a we
see the sir Matrix for panel B has not
only more boxes that are red but within
the boxes the actual values are higher
so that's why we have to use more
caution when we design a panel B but
it's certainly not completely impossible
to do
okay now we're going to switch again
into our third scenario which is cells
uh with high autofluorescence you can
see our little icon in the upper right
hand corner is now switched to the
number three so how do you figure out if
you're in this scenario or not well if
you have no idea I would say start out
before you do any panel design at all
take some unsane cells and run them on
your cytometer and that will give you an
idea of how much autofluorescence you
have this is especially easy to do on a
scitec system if you're using a
conventional system you are going to
need some optimized settings to be able
to make this call
so in our three examples here on the top
we have red blood cells intensity in
these plots is on the y-axis so we can
tell that the intensity of the unstained
red blood cells is pretty low
in the middle plot we have lymphocytes
so those generally are not too high and
they're kind of on the lower end but our
third example alveolar macrophages those
are very highly autofluorescent and if I
gave these a value I would generally say
that these alveolar macrophages are at
least sitting at 10 to the four and
there is no stain in these at all so we
do need to pay attention to how we
design our panel if we are in this High
Auto fluorescence situation and another
note if you are going to run your
unstained cells prior to doing any panel
design I would certainly recommend that
you record a ton of events so if you're
planning on running 200 000 events in
your final sample your multi-color
sample run about that many in your
unstained to make sure that you can
fully assess all of the autofluorescence
in your sample and there aren't any rare
populations that will surprise you later
so what do you do if you're in this High
autoflarson situation uh if you're in
the low autoflarson situation like the
lymphocytes you're going to ignore what
I say right now this is only for those
of you who are in that high autosarson
situation the fluorochromes listed here
are ones that typically have a emission
Maxima that overlaps in regions where
there is a lot of autofluorescence so
you have to be aware that there is a
potential for you to have lower
resolution with these particular floor
crumbs and you may need to be strategic
about how you put these in your panel
and again depending on your panel if you
have a very small panel and you are able
to not include a floor chrome let's say
bv421 tends to be a pretty difficult one
so maybe you just don't include bb5 or
sorry did I say bv421 I meant bv510 so
bv510 you might just not put that in
your panel and leave that channel open
that's one option if you have the
availability to do that but if you want
to include that then in the next section
I'll talk about some strategies you can
use to include these floor crumbs
so at this point we have gone through
Gathering a ton of information about
both the markers and the fluorochromes
now with that information I am going to
talk about how you would go about
designing a panel first I'm going to go
through a tool that we provide to you at
scitec it's called it's in scitec Cloud
it's called panel Builder
and then I will actually give you some
examples for Designing some panels in
these various scenarios that we have
been going through
so for scitec cloud it's a tool that we
have recently released there's a ton of
really great information in there it has
all of the tools that I've already
mentioned up to this point it also has
all of our kits listed it has all of the
omips are listed in there as well so if
you want a starting place you can start
from a kit you can start from an omit
that's an option for you but if you want
to sign up for a free account you can
just go to
cloud.sitechbio.com and create your own
account
let me show you some or how the panel
Builder works so this is a screenshot of
the main area that you will use to
design your panel using the best
practices that I'm going through today
in this talk at the top we have our
Specter viewer
in this main portion here we have our
panel Matrix and I do want to point out
that in the panel Matrix the stain index
is built in so there's going to be a
colored bar underneath each fluorochrome
and that colored bar is going to
indicate the brightness of the
fluorochrome on the system that you have
selected for your panel so if you choose
a five laser system it will show you the
brightness for a five laser system you
also will get a bar underneath the
marker name separately from the bar
underneath the floor chrome and the one
under the marker is something that you
can manually set yourself to help you
keep in mind what is the antigen density
of that particular marker
we also have the similarity index that's
going to calculate based on the
fluorochromes that you've put into your
panel Matrix as well as the stain index
reduction Matrix to give you a sense for
the worst case scenario of spread and
that's going to calculate specifically
based on the fluorochromes that you have
in the panel Matrix which is really
really awesome
and then to design your panel you have a
list on the left there and so you can
type in a fluorochrome when you do that
you will get all the available options
if the option does have a little scitec
icon that little rainbow circley thing
uh that will indicate that that
particular antibody is actually in our
reagent catalog or one of our
partnership region catalogs you can also
interact with the panel Matrix as well
and so any information that you enter
will show up both on the list on the
left as well as in the panel Matrix so
this is a really handy tool to use all
of these best practices to design your
panel
when you're done with your panel you can
export that as a PDF you can send it to
a friend inside techcloud or you can
also use the create experiment button
which will create an experiment template
that you can load onto any scitec system
and basically you will just be able to
show up at the cytometer and immediately
start running your samples
so let's get into our situations again
and go through some example panel design
so moving back to our simple scenario
where we have a smaller panel
let's go through the process of
assigning your fluorochromes to your
markers
so we're going to start out with our
tertiary antigens recall that I said
it's incredibly important to pair your
tertiary antigens with the brightest
floor crumb that you have available
oftentimes these tertiary antigens have
some limited region availability as well
so it's good to place these ones first
then you're going to work your way down
the line so we're going to move to the
secondary antigens and those are going
to go to any bright dye that you still
have available or any mid bright dies
and then primary antigens can go to any
remaining dyes in a smaller scenario
it's not quite as critical where you
place these but oftentimes the dim dies
work well but specifically for smaller
panels I probably am not going to be too
concerned if you pair it with something
that's a little bit brighter
now let's use this example we're going
to design a seven color panel on a four
laser scitec Aurora so we're going to
start out by classifying our antigens on
the top there we have cd25 we can see
that the positive signal is pretty low
so we're going to categorize this one as
a tertiary antigen
the middle row we can see that they
either have intermediate density like CD
127 or there's a range that we're trying
to resolve both low and high density
antigens so we're going to call those
when secondary antigens and then the
third row hasn't very clear on off
pattern so we're going to call those
ones our primary antigens
now we can use a gating strategy if we
want it's always a great idea to start
out with a gating strategy but for the
smaller panels it's not going to be
incredibly critical for us to pay
attention to co-expression
so when we design our panel we're going
to start with the tertiaries we're going
to assign that to the brightest floor
available so I'm going to select PE for
that
then we're going to move down the list
to the secondary antigens we're going to
assign mid-brite floors for that
so we're going to go with these three
here you'll notice that we have
different colors in those bars so the
purple indicates that that's primarily
excited by The Violet laser and then the
actual
a
intensity I guess of that bar is going
to indicate the brightness of that
fluorochrome so you can see that bv421
the second one is not as bright as PE
PES our maximum brightness but in
general we still think of bb421 and APC
as pretty bright fluorochromes
then the we're going to move to the
primary antigens and we are going to
pair those with any mid or dim floor
crumbs
and so those are the ones we select and
then the last thing we do is we're going
to select a viability die strongly
recommend that you put a viability die
in any panel and typically those can go
anywhere you want as long as they're
still unique from your floor crumbs that
you're trying to look at your markers
with unless you want to use a dump
Channel there are ways to combine a
viability die and a dump Channel which
means the dump channel is those
exclusion markers that you are removing
cells from your analysis so anything
you're not interested in
now if you want to do a quick check of
our panel design we can see that there
are two fluorochromes that are primarily
excited by The Violet laser too excited
by the red laser too excited by the blue
laser and one excited by the yellow
green laser So based off of that
everything's pretty well spread out I've
done a pretty good job of selecting my
floor crumbs and I'm not going to pay
more attention than that it's pretty
straightforward when you have a small
panel
of course if you want to do something
that's a little bit larger then we need
to be a little bit more cautious in our
design so we're going to go through the
same steps uh but I'm gonna add some
some things for you to think about so
our first step is going to be exactly
the same we're going to pair our
tertiary antigens to the brightest Floor
come available
our secondary antigens are where things
change we're going to start to need to
pay attention to co-expression the more
complicated your panel is the larger it
is the more critical it is for you to
pay attention to co-expression so if
there is no co-expression
then you can place your antigen wherever
you want you can use any die that's
still available however if you do have
co-expression that's where we need to be
careful I would refer to the sir Matrix
and we want to make sure we are
minimizing any impact of spread
and then finally we have our primary
antigens this is where it's much more
critical to pair these with dim
fluorochromes that is the strategy we
use to minimize spread
so let's look at our example now with a
19 color panel so a lot larger than our
first example of seven colors we have a
few tertiary antigens we have a lot of
secondary antigens couple primaries and
then our last case is special so you'll
notice we actually have two categories
there so we have CD4 and CD3 which are
listed both as primary and tertiary
and this is because we're using a
stimulation condition so in the
stimulated condition we have markers
that are uh going to be internalized so
they become tertiary as they get
stimulated so we need to pay attention
to that in our panel design
so using our panel Matrix we have
selected fluorochromes we're going to
start out with our tertiary antigens
we're going to place interferon gamma
tnf Alpha and CD 127 on bright floor
chrome so remember how we have the bar
underneath the fluorochrome indicating
the bright floor crumbs so PE APC and
APC r700
then we want to pair our special
um two floor crumbs the C4 and CD3 to
accommodate those low density engines
it's really important to accommodate the
tertiary antigen so we're going to pair
very bright fluorochromes
then moving to the secondary antigens we
are going to again just move down the
list in brightness and pair those
secondary antigens with any remaining
bright fluorochromes or any mid-rite
dyes that we have and as we go through
and place those secondary antigens we're
going to refer to the sir Matrix and
minimize spread so I'm going to go
through one of them but you would do
this for every single secondary marker
that you are placing
so we're going to do the example with
ccr7 I've placed that on bb421 so we're
going to look in the row for that and
we're going to look across the row for
bb421 and we're going to compare it to
the tertiary markers that we have
already placed and we can see that the
Box doesn't have any value in it so the
value is really zero and so this is good
because our ccr7 is not going to impact
the resolution of any of the tertiary
markers that we have placed so we like
this placement here
moving to the next step we are going to
place our primary antigen so we have the
three primary antigens in Orange we have
put those on dim fluorochromes buv615
per CP and per CP vio700 and so again
with the primary antigens we are going
to want to still assess the spread and
see if there's any issues with the
placement that we have selected
so going back to our sir Matrix I'm
going to check it for cd45 we've decided
to put that on Percy p . so looking
across the row for per CP we're going to
see where is there a value and it turns
out we have a value of 50 for the column
for per CP virus 700 which we've placed
with tcrv Delta one
so the there's a couple things to think
about when you have when you have a
value so first is it coexpressed is cd45
coexpressed with TCR uh V Delta one and
in in this case it is Coke's breast so
we are going to need to pay attention to
this value the second is what is TCR V
Delta one it's a primary marker so that
tells us we have really good separation
between our positive and negative
populations uh and then it's pretty
highly expressed so that's another
consideration to take in uh and then
also what's the value in the box so the
value there is 50. this value is a
percentage so it's out of 100 so 50 out
of 100 is not the highest value it's
like an intermediate value so given that
even though it's co Express it's not the
highest value it's 50 and our marker
that's receiving the spread tcrv Delta
one is a primary marker so because
there's good separation it should be
able to handle a little bit of spread
coming from cd45 and so based on these
I'm going to take a chance that I
probably can still resolve tcrv Delta 1.
and so I'm going to move on to the next
step which is assigning our viability
die again as long as that doesn't impact
our fluorochromes it's Unique from the
fluorochromes I can stick that anywhere
so I'm going to go with live dead blue
now why can't I stick that anywhere
because you might look at the sir Matrix
and see that there are some concerning
values in this there's some pretty high
values in that row but keep in mind that
with your viability die the positive
cells the dead cells are going to be
fully removed from your analysis so
assuming you titrated that properly
everything that's positive is going to
get removed and therefore we can
basically just ignore this entire row
because anything that is positive for
the viability die is not going to be
co-expressed with any cells that you're
actually interested in looking at
so we've designed our 19 marker panel
and the last thing we want to do is
check the whole Matrix and see how we
did I'm going to go through and look for
any sort of high values so I'm going to
pull out four values here are kind of on
the high side and I want to would want
to think through
um am I concerned about being able to
resolve any of these markers or do I
think that I've done a good job so in
this case I'm just going to go with it
and I'm going to see how this panel
looks on some actual real cells but if
you decide that you are concerned about
your resolution of markers you may go
back and rearrange some markers
but don't forget there is another step
after this
but before we get to that step I do want
to go through our last scenario which is
uh strategies if you have highly Auto
fluorescent cells uh and so I called out
earlier that bv510 was a fluorochrome
that oftentimes is difficult to use when
you have high autofocents so our
fluorocrine for bb510 is on the right
there and on the left there I have two
signatures for unstained cells the
neutrophils on the top which are on the
brighter side and the lymphocytes on the
bottom which are on the lower side
so if you have the situation that you're
trying to use a highly Auto fluorescent
cell type like neutrophils and you
overlay the bb510 on top of that you can
see how easy it is to get the same
intensity between the bb510 positive
cells and the neutrophils so in order to
be able to resolve a neutrophil marker
with bb510 we have to keep in mind that
that positive signal needs to be higher
than the actual background so in this
case we're saying that the background is
10 to the 4. it's going to depend on
what your tissue is and there's some
other examples listed there in the teal
box of fluorochromes that are
um have similar issues to bv510
however if we put bv510 on the lymph
sites uh you can see that now because
the lymphocyte autosources is lower it's
a little easier to separate the bb510
positives from the lymphocyte
autofluorescent background
so a different strategy you could use is
you could if you happen to have a tissue
like whole blood in this case that has
both neutrophils and lymphocytes in it
you could strategically pair the
problematic fluorochromes like bb510
with a lymphocyte marker because the
lymphocyte marker has the lower
autofluorescence compared to the
neutrophils
now viabilities with viability dies with
highly Auto fluorescent samples is a
little bit more challenging so in the
other situations I said stick the
viability die wherever you want in this
case there is some strategy so on the
left side we have our unstained cells on
the right side we have three different
viability dyes and if I overlay the
unsane cells and the viability dies
notice how I put a little purple Arrow
to distinguish the emission Maxima of
the viability die compared to the
unstained cells you'll see that in the
bottom plot you get the most separation
because dyes that are excited by the red
laser are probably going to be the
easiest to use in terms of viability
because oftentimes the red laser doesn't
have a lot of autofluorescence so you
get the best separation so that would be
my recommendation if you have a highly
autofluorescent sample use a viability
dye that's excited by the red laser
now we can move on to our final step
which is the optimization this is where
we actually determine if your panel is
successful or not now how do we do that
we're going to have to run an experiment
and get some data because we need to
figure out if we can actually resolve
all of our populations and markers of
interest if we can our panel is
successful if we cannot then we may need
to adjust our panel
so I would recommend doing something
that I call a panel optimization
experiment
but before we can get to that we
actually need to go through some
Readiness criteria for that panel
optimization experiment so you need to
start out by titrating your antibodies
you're going to be in a single color
scenario while you titrate your
antibodies and that's going to allow you
to confirm that you have optimal
resolution in the single color scenario
so it's very critical step then you're
going to also need to figure out how you
create high quality single color
reference controls or maybe you call
them compensation controls whatever
single stained controls you need to
follow the best practices for those and
that will allow you to calculate
accurate unmixing so the second and
third points kind of go hand in hand
ultimately you need to calculate
accurate on mixing and compensation and
you need to have that all dealt with
before you can actually do a analysis of
your panel optimization experiment
I also want to talk about how you would
actually set up your panel optimization
experiment the design for it is maybe a
tiny bit different than you're used to
so the first thing you want to do is you
want to make sure that you're bringing
your single color reference controls or
if you want to call them compensation
controls basically whatever you're using
to calculate to Accurate on mixing or
compensation you need to bring those so
that you can calculate the mixing and
compensation doesn't matter what it is
it could be beads because B cells just
as long as it gets you accurate on
mixing and compensation
the second thing is we want to combine
those
markers are our panel into one tube so
you're going to bring in a multi-color
sample I would say ideally you want to
run this on your final sample type but
there may be situations where you don't
do that so if you want to use a healthy
donor instead of one of your patient
samples just know that if you use an
alternative your panel might behave a
little bit differently especially if
there's a drastic difference in the
marker
antigen density between a patient and a
healthy donor so proceed with caution
and the last thing you have to bring
that is critical to this panel
optimization experiment is you need to
bring single color cells that are the
exact same tissue as your multi-color
sample so you need to have the setup
where your multi-color sample and single
stain cells are the same in every single
way except for the number of antibodies
in the tube that's what we're going to
be analyzing in this panel optimization
experiment now depending on your setup
you might be using these cells to
calculate compensation or on mixing so
you might already have them but in the
event that maybe you're using beads to
calculate compensation or a mixing for
this panel optimization experiment you
specifically also need to bring single
color cells
the last point about setup is for those
of you who might be doing something a
bit larger I don't want to fully
quantify larger I feel like it depends
on your comfort level so whatever you
are comfortable with in terms of panel
size and what you feel is a large panel
which you may feel uncomfortable running
at this point I would suggest if you're
in that scenario so I guess I will throw
out numbers if you are currently
comfortable with 10 colors and you want
to do 20 colors just as an example
I would recommend optimizing a subset so
just pull out 10 markers that's what
you're comfortable with Focus fully on
optimizing the 10 markers this is going
to be super easy to optimize and then
when you have that nailed down then you
can move up to your full panel that's
going to be the easiest way to make it
through this
now to analyze this data you're going to
be comparing the single color cells to
the multi-color cells and assessing
resolution so it's important to
understand that there's actually quite a
few factors that impact the overall
resolution of your markers
so there's a list on the right there you
can see instrument performance and setup
your antibody titration antibody
performance whether or not you have high
Auto fluorescent cells or not if you
have appropriately selected a
fluorochrome that is bright enough for
your marker and if there's any unmixing
or compensation errors now you notice
all of these things this is why we have
the Readiness criteria so you need to
optimize all these things when you are
setting up before the the actual panel
optimization so that when you get to the
panel optimization you know that all of
these things are already optimized and
you've specifically set up your
experiment in a way that we can compare
the single stain and the multi-color
scenario and assume that any difference
in resolution is coming from spread
which would then mean we are assessing
our panel
so let's get into some actual data of
doing this assessment I've overlaid
single stain cells in the Gray Line and
multi-color cells in the black line so
starting on the left there with our
cd45ra this one actually looks quite
good to me we have pretty similar
intensity for the positive population
and the spread in the negative
population is the same so there's no
issue with this marker we're happy with
the resolution
in our second example we can start to
notice that the negative population is a
little bit wider in the multi-color
scenario compared to the single in stain
scenario so I am being a little bit more
alert now the first thing I would do
since histograms can be a little bit
challenging to look at I would first
move to a Dot Plot and if I look at the
Dot Plot I can see that I can resolve
the cd19 positive cells so I would say
this actually is not really an issue
that I'm going to be concerned about and
happy with this marker
then I'm going to move to the next
example cd25 we have the same setup
where our the width of the negative the
spread and the negative is a little bit
wider in the multi-color scenario
compared to the single stain scenario so
this one's a little more complicated
we're going to investigate this one on
the next line
and then the last one CD 127 this one's
different instead of the negative
population we're seeing differences in
the positive population where the
positive population intensity in the
multi-color is a little bit dimmer so
this one actually would relate to
staining I would say you would need to
investigate your staining in this sense
this wouldn't be related to your panel
design so that since this talk is about
panel design I'm going to focus on the
panel of design changes and I'm not
going to go into detail about the
staining changes
so let's look at cd25 and we are going
to figure out what are the next steps we
would do to investigate this so the next
step would be you're going to gain every
population of interest in your panel
because it may turn out that the source
of the spread may not be co-expressed
with our markers so cd25 maybe the
spread is coming from cells that are not
cd25 positive however if you go through
and gate out all of your populations and
you find that you can't find the
populations that you're interested in
looking at then it may you probably need
to change your panel at that
so doing this with our cd25 example I
just separated these out into individual
plots so we have our multi-color plot at
the bottom you can see there's a lot
going on in the negative in terms of
spread so let's change this to a Dot
Plot because it's a little easier to
interpret and in this case I put the
cd25 on the y-axis so our spread is
happening vertically we can see that
there's definitely something going on
but in this case I did not gait on
anything so this is just all of the
cells generally if I actually went
through and gated my population of
Interest so in this case I'm interested
in cd25 on my CD3 and CD4 positive cells
and now if I look at that specific
subset I can see that I can actually
really nicely resolve my cd25 positive
cells now this plot looks exactly as I
was expecting it to look like
now if I want to really investigate
where did this come from I would go back
to the sir Matrix I would look at a
column for cd25 all down the column for
cd25 look for high value and I would
find that C4 by g610 has a value of 85
percent compared so it could potentially
reduce the resolution of cd25 quite a
bit but we paired that with cd16 so if
we look at cd25 versus cd16 look at that
that's where our spread is coming from
so that's how the sir Matrix is telling
us information but you'll notice that
they're not co-expressed so this was
actually a well-designed panel and so
essentially we can ignore this value of
85 percent in the SR Matrix because
these markers are not co-expressed
the last check we can do if you recalled
when we did a theoretical check of your
panel and you had some areas where you
maybe were a little bit concerned so we
see that value of 95 percent let's check
the data look at that we can resolve our
CD4 just fine so even though we had a
High
um
sir value as long as we were smart about
our panel design we can still get a good
panel out of that
so just to wrap up I talked about a lot
of tools and I want to point out just
one more so we have something called our
spectral learn educational portal if you
thought I went through some of the
earlier Concepts a lot faster we have
some short videos around five to ten
minutes that go into those Concepts a
little bit more in detail so feel free
to check those out and keep an eye out
for new ones that we are releasing you
can find our similarity and complexity
index values on our Spectrum viewer at
spectrum.scitec bio.com and you can find
the panel builder at cloud.sitechbio.com
so quickly summarize I know we're
running out of time I went through the
fundamentals of panel design and how
they apply to all cytometers and panels
of all sizes we went through some
additional considerations that are
appropriate for complex panels and
samples that have very high out of
fluorescence and we talk about how you
can actually run a panel optimization
experiment to actually assess marker
resolution and figure out if your panel
is successful
so with that I could take a couple
questions
great thank you so much Laura for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen now let's get
started so a question here is do you
need to do a panel optimization
experiment if you have a small panel
yeah so it's always a good idea to test
out your panel before you do a real
experiment with some very precious
samples but certainly if you have a very
small panel then it may not be quite as
critical uh whereas if you have a larger
panel then it's definitely very critical
to do that panel optimization experiment
before you run any sort of real
experiment
okay thank you and the next question
here is do you have any pre-designed
panels available
yeah so we have a bunch of kits
available and so you can check our
website scitec bio.com to see what kits
we have available and we're also
releasing more in the coming months and
you can also find those kits not only on
our website but they are also in scitec
cloud and so even if you wanted to use
the kits as a starting place inside Tech
Cloud that's an option for you as well
or just view them in scitec cloud is
another option
thank you and we'll wrap with this last
question is do you have a recommended
viability die
yeah so on a spectral system to give you
the maximum number of fluorophores
available I would say live dead blue and
vidi red and zombie nir are ones that
are nice solely because they just don't
share any similarity to any floor crumbs
that you would want to use for an
antibody But ultimately you can use
whatever viability dye you want unless
you have a highly autofluorescent sample
then I would recommend using something
excited by a red laser
great thank you so much Laura for your
time today and your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor scitec biosciences for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts and before we go I just like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for all their interesting questions
all the questions we didn't have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye